bonjour monsieur arthaud bonjour
monsieur roy merci de nous avoir écrit
oui
on est dans votre jardin
au parc angrignon
sud ouest de montréal et ça vous rend
triste de voir qu'on le laissait aller
complètement disons que pour beaucoup de
monde dans le quartier les
arrondissements environnait le parc
angrignon depuis des années
il ya eu d'investissements importants
tous les bâtiments sont fermés depuis au
moins plus que 10 au moins une dizaine
d'années donc comme les quartiers
anciens quartiers d'hiver qu'on est ici
à côté de l'image savante la décrépitude
du parc la tarte au sucre mais danic des
citoyens sonne la cloche en disant peut
pas les salles est un joyau comme ça si
on regarde l'histoire où il ya eu
beaucoup de promesses de projets en 2013
2015 les règlements d'emprunt était fait
et où seuls des projets étaient comme à
être réalisés et jamais rien ne s'est
réalisé donc on veut pas que cette même
situation ne se reproduise parce que
c'est magnifique lassant rayspan ific
parce que des arbres il faut il faut il
donner de l'amour maastricht mais ce
soit parce que il y est considéré comme
un des grands pas puisque deux
particularités les classiques ont
perturbé comme le parc la fontaine mais
il ya une majorité de ces sections qui
considérait on a protégé comme un pack
nature
donc il ya comme double vocation au
teint de parc urbain que d'un milieu
naturel de valeur quand même assez
exceptionnel c'est le seul grand parc de
tout le sud-ouest de données de montréal
puis comme un grand dans son confort ou
pas que la fontaine c'est presque trop
au foie l'espère site du parc lafontaine
bien si vous voulez aller aux toilettes
si avec votre famille il ya je sors se
sont ralliés aucun bâtiment qui tout va
non donc il s'agit pas de réinventer la
roue mais on dit il faut s'occuper de
nos affaires c'est sur faut s'assurer de
préserver
c'est cette qualité le de parc parce
qu'à l'intérieur du parc qui aussi des
des plans qui sont même classés
vulnérables comme le trade blain qu'on
retrouve ici un très grand homme qui
commence est de plus en plus rare dans
les parcs de montréal on en a profité
mais il le fait que les gens se
promènent partout dans le boisé fons
capelle on n'est pas l'essentiel ici tu
puisses une part tout ça ma pire il à
long terme cette plante aussi donc ça
fait partie 6 2
de ce qu'on veut qu'il soit préservée
pour garder ça pour les générations
futures merci beaucoup mais surtout
grâce à vous on est mieux informé qu'on
va aller poser la question au maire
d'arrondissement d'auray qu'est ce qui
attend pour mettre un peu
d'investissements ici de merci merci
beaucoup
je devrais bonjour bien bonjour quel
lieu merveilleux pour se voir c'est
c'est vraiment merveilleux et
fantastique
au niger on les choisit monsav de on est
chez nous non seulement parce que je
suis mal mais parce qu'il a quarante six
ans que j'habite l'arrondissement du
sud-ouest alors livré machine bon là
monsieur art où le citoyen est inquiet
il y en a plusieurs qui sont inquiets on
a laissé ce parc est à l'abandon
pourquoi d'abord tout d'abord c'est vrai
pendant des décennies le parc angrignon
a été laissé à l'abandon par plusieurs
administrations successives et ce qu'il
fallait c'était travailler dès le début
du mandat avec les services centraux et
on leur a dit il faut réinvestir dans le
parc angrignon ça fait quand même quatre
ans pourquoi il n'y a rien qui a été
fait parlons du passé on va parler de
l'avenir proche là mais priez rien qui a
été fait ça débloquait pas pourquoi
parce que t'es trop ambitieux le plan c
est pourquoi ç'a débloqué
m premièrement on peut pas tout faire
dès le début du mandat un certain nombre
d'études qui devaient être faites l'ont
pas des études qui servent à toutes
sortes d'affaires il nous fallait des
vraies stratégies pour pour se dire que
la forêt laurentienne et s'il on doit
vraiment lui redonner ses droits ce
qu'on voulait faire c'était de se dire
considéré avec les gens nous demandent
de réorienter la population du parc
angrignon 1 pendant longtemps cette
montre est l extension de la ronde les
gens venaient ici faisait le parti fait
cette histoire d'affaires on veut poste
le parc au besoin d'être chouchouté
morceau par morceau pour faire changer
les mentalités et les investissements en
r d vous êtes aux gens en conclusion du
sud oues est d'ailleurs que angrignon
vote
va se réformer va se moderniser en
termes d'accès aux toilettes en termes
de sentiers d'ici quoi 2,3 environ 2 3
ans parce que déjà on a revu les
panneaux de signalisation des gens à
planter des arbres il ya 3500 80 arbres
qui ont été faits pour la propreté
onomie 62 nouveaux nouvelles poubelles
une petite vite le quartier d'hiver vous
fait quoi avec sa démolition non non non
non ça c'est patrimoniale donc ça c'est
patrimoniale avec moi c'est vraiment le
pôle d'accueil du parc angrignon ce
qu'on veut c'est vraiment oui tout à
fait un chalet puis on rénove c'est ici
un petit café et thé des choses ce qui
vont du choix oui mais si on n'est pas
rendu à ce niveau de détail moi je veux
surtout préserver le bâtiment
patrimonial qui est là enfin
effectivement un chalet d'accueil puis
les gens nous dirons comment ils veulent
justement l'opérer nous ce qu'on
voudrait c'est une entreprise d'économie
sociale ça ça ressemble au sud ouest
c'est ce qu'on veut pour preuve les
quartiers d'hiver j'adorais mon va
suivre avec attention merci suivez nous
parce que ça va être